many time Oscar winner and the NBA's top
rebounder Republican Congressman George
Anthony devolder Santos is now
apparently uh being accused of having
been involved in a skimming operation a
skimming operation there is a Brazilian
man who has submitted a sworn
declaration saying that George Santos
was in charge of a fraud scheme that led
to this other guy's arrest in 2017 for
installing skimmers at a Seattle Bank
ATM now what's a skimmer skimmer is you
place a device over or around where you
would normally insert your or swipe your
ATM card and when you do that it
collects your data as well as your PIN
code that's the gist of it if this is
true it would be completely unsurprising
George Anthony devolder Santos has to go
I don't know that he's going to go but
we continue to follow it the guy's an
embarrassment